SCP-1504 is an otherwise normal man who seems
to be invulnerable to all forms of harm and
is held in a standard human containment cell.
He knows his name is Joe, but does not seem
to be able to recall his last name, which
has led to him being given the nickname “Joe
Schmo”..
He was brought to a nearby SCP containment
site without incident to be interviewed and
studied.
At first glance, it seems like it is one of
the least interesting entities in SCP containment,
but this seemingly uninteresting man turned
out to be a far more complicated case than
anyone at the Foundation expected.
Dr. Loyd was not anticipating a difficult
interview when he stepped into the containment
cell to speak with SCP-1504.
The mystery man was cooperative, answering
questions, although there were some abnormalities.
Not only did this man not know his own last
name, but he didn’t know when he was born.
As the interview went on, Dr. Loyd suffered
a spontaneous nosebleed and had to briefly
leave the room.
Dr. Loyd returned and the interview went smoothly
- until he asked 1504 about the origin of
his invulnerability.
The subject began crying and refused to talk
about it, and was released to his room.
That’s where the trouble began.
Dr. Loyd normally ran a rather calm site,
with high-tech security systems that were
effective at containing the entities inside.
As long as the technology worked, the staff
was in no danger - and it was designed to
be foolproof.
Or so they thought.
The technical hiccups began slowly.
Doors would open when they weren’t supposed
to, but the resulting breaches were quickly
contained.
These new issues were worrying, but as long
as they stayed manageable, the staff could
keep everything under control.
But of course, things didn’t stay manageable.
The site had one dangerous keter entity on
hand that breached containment.
When it broke out, the staff who specialized
in re-containing anomalies were alerted but
only about half responded.
The other missing half were all dead.
The remaining staff barely survived and managed
to contain the Keter, but their troubles were
only beginning.
Requests for more staff went ignored.
Supply drops didn’t arrive, and the staff
was quickly beginning to run out of the basics.
The deaths on site weren’t acknowledged
by the Foundation - or even many of the people
on site.
It was as if they had never happened.
Things were going from bad to worse - and
the true horrors lay ahead.
One day all the doors at the site suddenly
opened at once, and the staff was quickly
overwhelmed by the freed and enraged entities.
Most died, and the surviving ones scattered,
seemingly unconcerned with finding any other
survivors.
The only one who seemed aware of what was
happening was Darryl Loyd, and he knew there
was no way to contain this breach.
His time was running out, and there was only
one thing left to do.
He wrote everything that had happened down
in a document and sealed it in the indestructible
vault.
The document opened with a chilling sentence.
“We didn’t know his true anomaly.
We didn’t know what he could really do.”
Then, Dr. Loyd activated the fail-safe that
every SCP site has - an on-site nuke that
can be triggered in the event of a breach
that would endanger the outside world.
The badly injured Dr. Loyd perished in the
blast, along with every surviving staff member
and many of the escaped entities at the site.
When Foundation staff dug through the rubble,
they found the document - although it was
badly damaged and parts were unreadable due
to blood stains having been smeared across
it.
Most of the anomalies kept at the site were
accounted for, but one entity was neither
confirmed killed or recaptured.
So where was Joe Schmo?
Not only was SCP-1504 not found on site, there
was very little record of him found on any
electronic systems or archives.
The only evidence found of this mysterious
man was the hand-written document left behind
by the late Dr. Loyd, as well as the initial
interview that seemed to show absolutely nothing
of note.
But Dr. Loyd’s last words worried the staff,
and a missing entity is never to be taken
lightly.
It was decided to run the interview footage
through multiple filters to rule out any perception-based
interference.
What they discovered turned out to be one
of the biggest threats in the SCP Foundation’s
history.
The interview started similarly, with Dr.
Loyd asking SCP-1504 what his name was.
But things soon took a turn from the original
log.
SCP-1504 was belligerent from the start.
He snapped “I’m not going to tell you.
You’ll just ignore me.”
His response was similar when asked when he
was born.
He even claimed that Dr. Loyd wouldn’t notice
if he punched him in the nose.
Dr. Loyd seemed undisturbed, acting as if
he had just been told a year instead of being
threatened.
Then SCP-1504 decided to test his theory.
The mysterious “Joe Schmo” leaped up from
his seat and punched Dr. Loyd.
The doctor’s nose began bleeding badly,
but he seemed to hardly notice, only commenting
that he had a nosebleed and leaving to take
care of it.
This made SCP-1504 even more agitated, cursing
at Dr. Loyd and desperately seeking to get
his attention.
As Dr. Loyd asked why he couldn’t seem to
be hurt, SCP-1509 lost his head.
He began an extended rant where he stated
that he could do anything to anyone, even
kill the people they love, and they wouldn’t
notice.
He claimed to be able to shoot himself with
the guard’s gun, and nothing would happen.
SCP-1504 was in tears, but no one seemed to
notice.
Dr. Loyd just kept writing notes as SCP-1504
ranted that he always felt like he was stuck
in a room crowded with people, and every single
one of them ignored him.
He expressed that he wished to die, but was
apparently unable to due to the nature of
his anomaly.
Dr. Loyd didn’t seem to hear any of this,
and instead thanked SCP-1504 for cooperating
with the interview and returned him to his
cell.
His perception of the interview was exactly
what the initial interview had been - completely
uneventful.
It was clear that SCP-1504 was much more powerful
than anyone knew - and now he was missing.
The Foundation met and quickly updated SCP-1504’s
classification from Safe to Keter.
The classification and description was pieced
together - slowly - due to the subject’s
cognitohazard abilities, which means that
any information known about him may be subjective
at any time.
A place for him was prepared at Area 114,
the Foundation’s primary location for containing
perception and sensory-based threats.
But SCP-1504 is not currently contained - and
his unique abilities mean he may never be.
After all, how do you contain something when
no one knows who or where it is?
But the Foundation is prepared.
There’s a cell waiting for SCP-1504 at the
site, a simple-looking 3 meter by 3 meter
by 3 meter chamber, but the security on hand
is anything but simple.
It will be kept closely guarded, with a minimum
of four Level 3 staff members required for
access.
Two staff members will stay inside the control
room ready to trigger security measures and
even the failsafe if a containment breach
happens.
The staff is ready to flood the cell with
Halothane gas if needed - one of the only
things that can incapacitate SCP-1504, along
with a sharp blow to the head.
He cannot be allowed to escape, and must be
confined and restrained at all times.
Any attempt to open the locks must be released
by multiple staff members at the same time,
and only one can enter the chamber to interact
with SCP-1504.
So what do we know about what makes SCP-1504
so dangerous?
Well, that depends on who you ask.
Because most people would say there’s absolutely
nothing dangerous or unique about him.
He’s just an average Joe.
And that’s exactly what makes him so dangerous.
SCP-1504 is a living cognitohazard that affects
the perception of everyone around him.
No matter what he does, it will be perceived
as normal, calm, and forgettable - and the
odds are anyone around him will forget his
existence only seconds after they meet him.
But that’s not his most dangerous ability.
In addition to his cognitohazard and his seeming
complete inability to be harmed beyond brief
incapacitation, SCP-1504 has the ability to
interfere with electronic systems - which
caused the catastrophic breach at his original
site.
Any automatic systems around him will start
to glitch, and as such his private cell at
site Area 114 is locked only with simple locks
featuring combinations and keys.
Testing on the range of his powers is ongoing,
and the site will take care to make sure a
total containment failure is never allowed
to happen again.
While the Foundation intends to minimize direct
contact with him once captured, any personnel
at Area 114 will already be trained in how
to resist perception shifts.
For any of this to work though, the Foundation
has to capture him first.
And therein lies the problem.
The Foundation was able to capture SCP-1504
the first time simply by reports of his inability
to be harmed.
That seems to be the one thing about him anyone
can notice.
Otherwise, no action he takes - even physically
attacking someone - will be memorable in any
way, allowing him to slip away undetected.
While physically, he is little threat to anyone,
there is reason to consider him a critical
danger to public safety.
His ability to disrupt electronic systems
means he could be a security risk to any public
facility - including banks, prisons, or even
nuclear power plants.
And there is reason to believe he may be growing
more unstable.
No one knows how old SCP-1504 is, or if he
has a normal lifespan.
His inability to be harmed indicates he could
be anomalous in other ways, and even if he
ages normally, it’s clear the isolation
of his abilities are making him increasingly
angry.
He seems to be getting more and more desperate
to be noticed by any means necessary - hence
his assault of the unfortunate Dr. Loyd.
And now he’s out there in the world, undetected
by anyone.
Who knows how he’ll try to make himself
famous - or infamous - next?
The Foundation has made the capture of SCP-1504
one of their highest priorities, and once
they get him, they intend to make sure he’s
never free again.
Now they just have to find him, and that’s
where many Foundation experts are stumped.
How do you find something that is designed
to go unnoticed?
Until they have an answer, their trackers
are on the search for reports of a normal-looking
caucasian man, just under six feet tall, with
a small birthmark on his right shoulder.
That should narrow it down.
For more on another unassuming man with unexpected
abilities, check out “SCP-343 - God”,
or watch “SCP-507 - Reluctant Dimension
Hopper” for another SCP whose control of
its abilities is lacking.